hello in this video we'll talk about
annexin 5pi assay and this is a fan
requested video
annexin 5pi assay is a common method to
detect apoptotic cells
the anexin 5 protein can bind to
phosphatidylserine residues on the
membrane
with high affinity in normal cells
phosphatidylserine is generally not
found on the outer leaflet it is
generally distributed in the inner left
leg so that is why in the normal cell
phosphatidylserine would never come in
contact with anexin 5 which is on the
outer side
now anexin 5 can interact with
phosphatidylserine in an apoptotic cell
only
this principle is based on the
heterogeneity in membrane lipid
distribution
several membrane lipids like
sphingomyelin phosphatidylcholine are
generally distributed in the outer
leaflet whereas phosphatidylserine is
generally
distributed in the inner side of the
leaflet
and in healthy cells it remains in the
inner side and never goes in the outer
side
so in this assay we need anexin 5 which
is actually a anticoagulant protein
anexin 5 has a very high binding
affinity with phosphatidylserine in
order to detect this binding process we
can conjugate
anexin 5 with a dye let's say fritzi and
later on detect it with flow cytometry
in this assay the pi or propidium iodide
is actually a dye that can penetrate the
membrane that can pass through the
membrane if the membrane integrity is
bad
so proprium iodide
is found inside the cell if there is a
membrane damage
now with the help of flow cytometry
these cells can be sorted and we can
understand and interpret the data in
order to start the assay you need anaxin
5 which is commercially available
propedium iodide which is also
commercially available and we need a
particular binding buffer which has
calcium chloride in it because annexin 5
requires calcium in terms of binding
first of all we need to remove the cell
culture media from our cells that need
to be tested
then we have to wash it with 1x pbs
and then we have to add the anaxin 5 and
pi working mixture
we have to incubate this solution in 15
minutes in a dark situation
such that binding can possibly happen
then it's time to analyze the samples
using flow cytometry
and the flow cytometry data would give
us
the
overall readout of how many cells are
apoptotic versus non-apoptotic let us
try to understand this with a very
simple example
in viable cell we know the
phosphatidylserine would be inside
so there would be no binding with
the anexin 5
in case of early apoptotic cell anexin 5
would be bound to these
phosphatidylserine which are exposed to
the outer side but the propidium iodide
cannot get inside because still the
membrane integrity is not so bad such
that propidium iodide can
get into the cells
now in let's stage apoptotic cells first
of all anexin 5 would be binding to the
phosphatidylserine as well as the
propedium iodide would move inside of
the cell because the membrane integrity
is totally messed up right now
there could be another situation where
the
propedium iodide has permeated through
the membrane but annexin 5 does not bind
and this is a situation which doesn't
involve apoptosis this is kind of a
necrotic situation which doesn't involve
the
movement of phosphatidylserine
into the outer leaflet so this is a
signature of necrotic cell and now let's
look at the flow cytometry plot to
understand this is how the flow
cytometry plot look like so the way you
read this plot is looking at the cell
numbers which are in these axis so
in the y axis you see these cell numbers
tells us that how many cell are positive
for p i whereas in
the the particular uh x axis tells us
how many cells are positive in the uh
and x in five positive cells so
obviously
we can see in the
um
lower quadrant
there are viable cells
which has low level of pi very low level
of annexin 5.
the early apoptotic cells would be in
the
lower down right side quadrant because
they would have
high level of anexin 5 but low level of
propidium iodide
now necrotic cells would be in the upper
left quadrant because in the necrotic
cells pi level would be high but anaxia
level would be low
and the late stage apoptotic cells would
be in the upper right quadrant because
they are both anexin and pi both of them
would be high and this is how we can
interpret
the
flow cytometry data now we have a
control cell and then some kind of
drug-treated cell we can kind of
understand
how much apoptotic
apoptosis has taken place and also we
can understand how many cells are at
early stage of apoptosis versus
let stage of apoptosis this can kind of
give us a sense about the efficacy of
the drug as well if it is meant to kill
the cells
so that is how anexin pi assay work i
hope this was useful this is a quick
summary for that if you like this video
support my channel on my patreon page
you if you're a indian viewer support my
channel using beam upi this is my qr
code your small contribution means a lot
for me don't forget to like share and
subscribe my channel my courses are also
present in an academy you can use my
code ap10 to get a 10 discount
see you in the next video